during the financial crisis people did
feel poorer they were losing their jobs
so they didn't feel like they should be
spending as much money right now we
don't have the same problem so people
aren't spending because they don't feel
like they should be spending they're not
spending because the stores are closed
and my cruise was canceled it's Sarah's
cruise being canceled that's really a
problem here not because she doesn't get
to go on vacation but because all the
cruises were canceled in fact entire
cities are shutting down all
non-essential businesses and services a
lot of people are out of work and even
if you do have money to spend there's
nowhere for you to go to spend it
because of all this the Federal Reserve
cut interest rates to 0% immediately
something called the Dow futures drop 5%
and trading was halted I wasn't quite
sure what this all meant so I asked one
of the smartest people I know
insiders own Sarah silverstein Sarah has
a degree in analytical finance worked on
Wall Street for many years and is
currently the host of Business Insider
today all of insider is following the
CDC guidelines to socially distance so
Sarah was kind enough to lay it out for
me over Skype so Sarah what is a Fed 0%
rate well so what it is is basically
exactly what we saw after the financial
crisis where feds cut interest rates all
the way to zero and that is basically a
benchmark that people can borrow from
the idea is if the Fed rate goes to zero
that my money in the bank that I'm
saving is basically losing money with
inflation so what the Fed has done is
made saving money unattractive by making
the rate 0% the interest you might earn
in a savings account becomes lower as
well in fact it's lower than inflation
so saving money means you're slowly
losing money because inflation will chip
away at it over time if I owe $100 in a
bank account today and I'm getting only
one percent interest in 10 years it
becomes about $110 but when you factor
in inflation it becomes about eighty two
dollars worth of buying power in ten
years time the fetish is really trying
to get people to spend their money that
doesn't mean that mortgage rates will go
to zero percent but it is a rate that
banks and institutions like that can
borrow from and so other interest rates
do follow
long and will lower when the feds funds
rate drops and will raise when the
federated Rises this isn't the first
time the rate has gone to 0% in fact
during the 2008 financial crisis the
rate was cut to a sliver above 0% and
stayed there for 8 years this is one of
the feds big tools it's its biggest tool
however when the Fed did it during the
financial crisis rates were above 5
percent so the difference for a consumer
who had money in the bank or who was
looking at bonds whereas the stocks are
saving for suspending that's a huge
difference making 5 percent on your
money versus making nothing but when the
Fed cut the rate to 0 on Sunday doll
futures plummeted now the Dow is a
basket of 30 stocks across various
industries meant to reflect the overall
economy if the Dow is up it's meant to
be viewed as a sign that the economy is
doing well if it's down there may be
trouble ahead Dow futures are used when
the market isn't open to predict what
the market might open act when the Fed
cut the rate to zero Dow futures plunged
5% and on Monday morning it went down
even further if an interest rate of zero
is a good thing why did it go down so
much we're coming from a 1 percent rate
which means that it's not as big of a
thing for investors usually when rates
are cut that leads the stock market to
rise but that didn't happen this time
which means one of two things people
expect rates to be cut and then they are
cut usually nothing happens or if
they're cut less than the market
expected
there's nowhere more it could have gone
so the other thing is that the Fed this
is something that we've been worried
about for a long time whenever the Fed
is at or close to zero it means if we
have a really big issue a really big
economic issue that the Fed can't really
do anything to help because interest
rates have been so low for so long the
Fed didn't really have a ton of tools to
work with here it's like meaning a
bazooka and only having a butter knife
the economy's been expanding a lot of
people a lot of economists have been
saying that the Fed should be raising
rates so that we have tools when
something bad happens and there's
nowhere left to go like the Fed is not
our saloon
and right now people are being told to
stay inside if they can so if they
aren't going anywhere and not spending
as much as they normally do and the
Federal Reserve is down for the count
what other options are left how do we
get the dala back up more importantly
how do we make sure people have money to
spend and even make rent fiscal policies
a lot of people and some of it is
politicized and some of its not but a
lot of people are saying that if the Fed
is out of bullets the only thing we left
is fiscal policy which is basically
injecting money into the economy not
through liquidity and lowering interest
rates but injecting money into the
economy either by cutting taxes or by
giving people money not like that but in
in programs that give people money
basically and what program is that like
bailouts universal basic income things
like that yes absolutely there are
already talks about some of these
programs happening in the House Senate
and White House some politicians like
senator Mitt Romney are suggesting
giving all Americans a certain amount of
money President Trump has been tweeting
his support for giving the Airlines
financial help it's hard to say right
now what any of these programs might
look like but it will require all of
Washington working together
you